hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to passing Pineview forest
now this horror game is a precursor to
another horror game called Pine View
Drive which people said wasn't as good
as it could've been
of people do say that this game is very
scary and very good and very well made
but I'll put that onto the desk because
I have no idea when it comes to using
the or games but it did look good and
the steam reviews were good and it was
all good and also a tree so there's that
it's not gonna give me a tutorial or
anything it's not gonna tell me what I'm
supposed to be doing it's not telling me
exactly what I'm supposed to be fearing
it's really dark oh good I have a
flashlight
that sounds sinister and horrible I
wonder why monstrosity awaits me I
wonder how many times I've said that a
beginning of the [ __ ] game I know it
said I was only passing through I highly
suspect that I'm actually going through
the forest oh I can run oh I could run
the whole time okay am I supposed to be
on the lookout for something because I
don't hear anything
is anybody up there in the wind blew
woods mmm anybody anybody at all
I shouldn't scream directly in the back
there ah no okay well then and you
believe that the music is crescendoing
oh thought I saw something nevermind it
was still a whole lot of nothing
I heard that whoa also heard that whoa
Stephon
you're just [ __ ] with me and I don't
think that you can fool me I'm a master
of horror games I've played a number in
my time
I know exactly your tricks you're full
of [ __ ] I don't blow hello I'll believe
you for a second I found my destination
finally whatever it may have been hello
anybody mind if I come barging into your
home and wreck up the place I only plan
to come into your home and wreck up the
place a little bit hello Green blood and
strange music I know this recipe it's
aliens all dope I can't go fast when I'm
going diagonal for some reason excuse me
this last steps a bit of a doozy
something's are skittering out there but
I don't know what it'd be kind of weird
house is this giant tall legged freaks
sit on a pie toilets and not have
bedrooms upstairs alrighty then I guess
that was fun I'll just be on my way
plus I missed an important detail which
I don't think I did
checked it pretty thoroughly what is
this I didn't even bring any nuts
we'd like to know it's skittering in the
forest besides small woodland creatures
of course highly palpable probable
method
what zas I heard a squeaky screw
somebody in the woods be squeaking whoa
oh dude
how are you sorry I have to look down
upon you from way up my nose bridge
thing god oh god with that what the fack
what game over why I didn't even know
what happened what was that what a load
of bull what happened will they come and
grab my face peekaboo gasp who's your
bird
upload a horse hockey hang on follow the
path through the pine wood forest until
the end but be quiet otherwise it will
take you oh it'll take me we're down to
pound townn okay so I read up a guide
about how to play this game and
apparently lumbering through the forest
like a giant idiot shouting my own name
is a bad way to play the game what I'm
supposed to do is I'm supposed to take a
very careful calm approach only turn on
the flashlight when I need it and not
just have it blaring on for anyone to
come up and grab my face which is just a
generally bad rule for life grabbing my
face not you know having a flashlight so
I'm supposed to be very very careful
about the audio cues because the audio
cues are there for telling me that I'm
about to die now I don't know how I got
as far as I did when I was just
lumbering through the forest but the
reason this game is here so I can take a
very calm very relaxed stroll through
the woods walk carefully
I'm actually gonna crank up my audio for
this one I had actually way down I don't
know why I do that I almost always do it
very loud and proud for these horror
games and I'm supposed to
I'm supposed to listen very closely for
the monsters are the ones and they're
not gonna come get me because I'm too
smart and handsome for them to handle
and then when I get to the end of this
road after calmly approaching it I win
the game and the only objective as far
as people said was to get to the end of
the road so that's exactly what I intend
to do one step at a time
oh they said not to trust any noise you
al bastard
okay I'm assuming that the farting brass
section is okay I'm just assuming that I
only need to be on the lookout for a
random noises it's the wind a random
noise prana
okay
just as a general rule if you're being
stalked by a murder in the woods don't
turn on your flashlight flail it which
way and then sprint wildly like a maniac
while lollygagging through the woods
bizarre trap just a Kaluga shut the [ __ ]
up it's bizarre because as I'm going
through the woods I can't quite see
what's in front of me so my mind is kind
of making up threats where they're not
really from the leaves and the noises oh
I could no stop it
that's it oh don't you do that
that's all loadable I'm surprised you
can't hear me screaming can I go now
this it seems to go
he walked up like right behind me whoa
so creepy
oh oh so creepy oh so weird right by me
and then squeaked a squeaker in my back
what was that was it was that thing
they said any noise
you too Ally you screechie bastard don't
go Hooton in my neighborhood okay
that musical track is really interesting
because it just keeps growing and
evolving throughout the entire game I
don't notice a point where it ever ends
it just keeps going i'ma just in case
just in case at night it's harder to
hear cuz the music
oh it's dark oh it's dark oh it's dark
oh it's dark oh it's dark
oh it's dark brah oh it's dark this that
was that giant turd do I want to know
what that is I don't I don't want to
know that is I'm not gonna yeah okay
okay okay what up G zones right in my
ear god damn it okay okay
something bad about Evan what is this
petition at San Jose hay bale oh okay
then all right that's cool I guess whoo
what is that oh oh it's a giant head
hello dude are you guarding something
do I even want to know what you're
guarding you know what never mind I'm
just gonna carry on my way goodbye
that's a different sound
yes
okay
okay okay
who what is that it's a shack
that looks like I can go in it either
what is that what is this War of the
Worlds
those are tripods what a stupid name for
aliens tribe shut up your names stupid
God I just started
Shawn
thank you
I'm probably taking this way slower than
I actually need to take it but you can
understand my caution I don't want to go
through this whole thing and not
actually be able to beat it what the
hell is that
Jesus I want to actually we believe this
what is that the eye sees is that dust
my eyes deceive me what is that what is
that what is this pray tell oh crap
you've got to be joking me I'm getting
flashbacks from my Louis's oh boy I
don't look behind me and Kay Suns been
following me in the entire time but here
we go
poor doo doo dee pull or dad or Neal or
dad or D totally fine we're totally fine
totally fine okey-dokey then
what is that not the end god damn it how
much farther do I have to go oh oh oh'
chill here for a little bit just a
little bit
Thanks
and here we go
hopefully nothing followed me across the
precariously perched bridge and if they
did follow me hopefully broke with the
thunderous crash to his own demise
then I shall be the victor that's what
he gets for following me so closely
Oh Oh what is this what is this what is
this shut the [ __ ] up
that's all I was dead you ass back son
of a [ __ ]
Pizza sure I just known as birds why are
there birds around here while there be
birds I don't like that that's probably
a bad sign
am I getting close to the end please I'd
like to belay finished
I've got to be getting close to the end
I've gotta me I've gotta be close to the
end I must be a million ways I must be
unless I've just been going in circles
this entire time better get some ice
cream after this is something I don't
even know I'm taking this shortcut I
don't believe you you're not an actual
noise you're [ __ ] the owl is
[ __ ]
I was full of [ __ ] okay maybe you're
not full of [ __ ] but I still don't
like you douche bananas do cycles douche
canoes it's obviously the best
oh oh oh I found it oh I found it
oh I found it I found it what why I
didn't train enough I didn't read it
I pushed one button the one time that I
push the [ __ ] button he decides to
put dialogue that's capable of being
skipped oh boy
well you guys could read what that was
in the one frame that it appeared please
pause to your own delight alright so
that game got a lot better once I took
my time with it once I was patient with
it it became a lot scarier but only
initially then it became oh this is how
I beat it it's this easy you know got
dull it's it's a unique thing but the
charm wears off a little quickly so it
was not bad let me know what you think
of it in the comments down below thank
you again everybody for watching and
check out the big playlist of scary
games that I played in the past there
are well over a whole bunch of hundred
of them so check it out in the
description or the annotation over there
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video so racist that
last match t14 rate was racist I wasn't
racist